how are the Duggars in the shot there oh
there are a couple of innovations in the
way that we approached Ellis's facial
work in that shockwave we had one
version that was much bigger
maybe you've discovered something that
we didn't even intend to put in the
movie hi welcome back to another very
special episode of visual effects
artists react today we are joined by
matt aitken now matt is one of the
visual effects supervisors at Wetty and
it's an incredible honor to have him
here on the show it's worked on a ton of
movies are you thinking from avengers
endgame all the way back to Lord of the
Rings he was in our Lord of the Rings
special and I'm the guy scanning the
head with a really early laser scanner
so cool tell us a little about what your
role is what does it mean to be a visual
effects supervisor my role is that I'm
kind of the contact point between the
team at where the digital you know
producing the visual effects work on a
given show and the people at the studio
like I work with the team at Marvel on
the Avengers films I'm providing you
know the finished visual effects shots
for them to go into their movie it's
like when you go to the dentist and you
have like the nurse that like works for
a while your teeth and then the dentist
comes in just like touches everything
briefly at the very end is that you
basically possibly so in-game was
actually nominated for an Academy Award
for Best Visual Effects we're also
nominated for the BAFTA which is the
British Academy of Film and Television
Awards so I get to fly my London go to
the BAFTAs and then come back here next
week for the Oscars visual effects were
so star-studded Inderjit City
[Laughter]
[Applause]
one of the scenes that you guys were
responsible for in Avengers endgame was
the climactic and battle scene yeah that
was pretty much what we did I work
started when they lost turns up in the
eighth ship and destroys the Avengers
compound and we go all the way through
to totally doing the snap and his
ultimate demise spoilers ahead everybody
not everybody this is a pretty shocking
moment movie it's like oh okay
say and roll credits in a shockwave that
giant explosion we worked on that a lot
because they had to look like it was
going to create this huge crater but at
the same time it couldn't look like it
just believable so we have our version
that was much bigger they were like yeah
that's great but nobody could survive
and this is all CG fire was at all
dynamics and simulation yep yeah for
sure
we shared the shot with ILM so the
sittin point here it becomes an i-i'm
shocked they did all this work here we
did all that the outside stuff you
should talk to them which I'd love to
come in as well okay I applied for an
internship
Wow why didn't you hire me I'm always
impressed by the level of consistency
between all the different effects houses
delivering the same character in
different scenes worked on by completely
different people yeah the team at Marvel
they do a lot of work in terms of giving
us each notes will show a version of
Thanos and they're like aspects of it
they'll take that shot and show it to
Dedes and you know we'll share geometry
and we'll share textures you know that
completely different assets so there are
two completely different 3d models of
Thanos you know that are brought up to
the exact same level of quality so you
can't tell the difference between them
well that's what we tried to achieve
succeeded I didn't realize they're
multiple different versions if you
enjoyed the show and you want to keep
watching well please consider
subscribing so that it shows up in your
subscription feed and you never miss it
I thought by eliminating half of life
the other half of thrive so when you
have a character like fan OHS it was
completely digital but obviously driven
by a real actor what are the main steps
between him acting and what we finally
see in the movie we wear your suit
that's market up so we'll get his body
performance from there and we'll also
dot up his face he'll be wearing a hit
Downton camera rig they're filming the
dots on his face as he performs often
what we do is we all do
motion capture that is happening at the
same time as the live action photography
so through infrared motion capture we
can capture the suit dots without
polluting the light that the director of
photography is creating on the set
understand how motion capture works and
movies they just kind of assume that the
motion is captured and then they're just
applied to a 3d model and that's all you
have to do so be amazing if a motion
capture really plays to creating his
movement but the number of times that we
have raw motion capture data going on to
tell us as zero we need to clean it up
but we also need to just find sell-offs
and the motion capture performance so
some of these fight beats were injected
josh i stuntman is performing the more
dramatic movements and we're motion
capturing the stunt ii but even then
he's still not gonna move the same way
as an eight-foot-tall muscle-bound right
Saros would move so the fantastic
animation supervisor on twitter sydney
combo can't on where he would dial in
what he would call the body mechanic of
Pharos so he's getting the weight and
maybe slowing down the movement a little
that's something that will keyframe on
top of the motion capture data as well
when you're dealing with this much armor
on a character can be really hard to
animate all of it and have it move
correctly and slide over itself it's not
clipping yeah so some people pointed out
to us and this one shot of this glove
you can see it's finger bits clip
through the dating a little bit I
thought we missed it is that something I
just nobody happened to see it until it
was out in theaters yeah how much should
we caught it at the time it just goes to
show there's always a little bit more
that you could do but ya know we're
doing a lot of work on the armor you
don't want to constrain what Josh is
doing on set you want him to be able to
perform and then you just have to make
the amur work to that so there's a lot
of sleight of hand going on bending of
things that should be rigid it comes
back to that thing of craft you know
bringing an ASUS hands-on crafts
approach to sculpt that suit enjoy very
much we talked about Thanos his face for
a moment sure dude the pores stretch
there are a couple of innovations in the
way that we approached their losses
facial work up until infinity war we
would go straight from the facial motion
capture of Josh to the performance of
Pharaohs what we started doing over
infinity war was introducing this
intermediary step which we call the
actor popper
we've got the footage of Josh from the
head mounted cameras we've got a digital
Josh and then we've got our digital
thermals and we can see very clearly if
it's deviating a little bit from what
Josh was doing and then it's actually a
reasonably straightforward process to
migrate the animation curves from one
puppet to the knees so what you're
telling me is that there's a perfect
digital double of josh brolin that you
can drop into every fan of kind of a
little bit like a Mission Impossible
pull off the last what's harder in your
opinion the mouth or the eyes I think
people mainly look at the eyes that's
often a criticism of digital performance
if it's not working that people say that
the eyes look did so we have to get the
eyes rise and we spend a lot of time
lighting the eyes so that they have a
nice highlight so we'll put a special
light and the scene and it's a little
small area light but quite bright then
the eyes will pick it up it'll have a
very subtle effect over the rest of them
[Music]
so green-screen you guys are using a lot
of green screen in this as well as
rotoscoping yeah how are you eating such
perfect edges in your green screen I
mean they're good green screens that
well lips and they're clean and then
we've got a lot of really highly
advanced techniques we're you know doing
parts of the hair differently you know
if we get something really gnarly you
might have to match move in a digital
version of the actor and replace the
plate here with CG here Wow
winter helmet comes off there is that CG
here for a brief moment for the 20 tail
to flip I think that's just a warp
actually and I think she might have
flicked her head that's that's the hell
of the duck shot where how are the
daggers in the shot right there
Oh 17 frames them ladies and gentlemen
and when the studio reviews they were
like I want to be great to get how the
duck of the movie somewhere so we had to
migrate the set it you know they sent us
so Howard the Duck Loomer head down for
guardians to they gave him one of the
ravaging guns just way too big from
I just noticed that each of those
portals have like a different color
scheme inside of it and it represented
the Infinity Gauntlet different colors
yeah they were those heavy flow you've
got what condo you got the blue of deep
space maybe you've discovered something
that we didn't even intend to put on the
movie you guys want to see us react to
any specific movies or TV shows please
leave a comment in the description below
let us know and we will take a look at
it I don't think anyone's ever seen just
so many like heroes on screen at a
single time the filmmakers you know
they've managed to balance all that
stuff so that it's personal a lot of it
as as these little beats you know that
we get these character moments and we
get you know the reunion of Tony and
Spidey it's that's the stuff that makes
it successful you know we we were just
really there supporting these these
fantastic character moments so out of
this entire sequence that would have
worked on what do you think was probably
the most challenging single shot of the
entire sequence there's a little shot
called the whether it was the scary part
of the cut for a long time for me but
now I can enjoy it
[Music]
so many layers of complexity everything
from clashing armies two-digit levels to
animation to like real-life meeting CG
at the same time for closure
we started working on it really early on
and it was one of the last shots to be
finished so we had like a subchannel
working on a head of Tony animation
supervisor at Sony animation team who
are building the elements of the shot
populating the scene we're iterating the
whole time so as soon as there's
anything that's even half decent we'll
pass that down the line to two
Lighting's all that lighting work is
going on at the same time as the
animation work what's really nice about
this is that the characters a rim lit by
their Sun so you have to really
coordinate where the light is so do you
work up like a master lighting position
going into a lot of this stuff one thing
we do do which is what exactly what they
do on sit or on location is don't worry
about the any sort of consistency to the
position of the Sun the kick the key
light so they'll always put that behind
the the character that they're filming
the thing I like to show people that
really explains that is a scene from the
very end of the first Independence Day
movie the Sun is always behind everybody
yeah which you don't have to do it
because if you were filming it from the
other side they would just be completely
burnt out so you're exposing for the
shadows we try and adopt these
principles because they're established
some amela graphic principles that work
so I know they for these scenes here
they actually film on a practical set
but do you end up having to replace any
of the foreground elements yes sometimes
we do there's a little bit of a set
element behind these guys here which we
kept because it was appropriate but we
did this thing where we essentially
lifted the actors off the seat and put
them with a predominantly CG environment
and that sounds like a lot of
rotoscoping so you basically cut out
each character and none of the
background is real just the characters
are real exactly yeah obviously Tony his
suit CG so whenever we see her room by
himself really the only thing we're
keeping us is hid anyway this was the
last shot that we delivered on the show
oh wow and it was about two weeks before
the premiere so it was getting it was
coming down to the wire
you know they had versions of the shop
but they kept wanting it to change a bit
so we were happy to keep working on it
the thing that was really important in
the end was showing that Tony is
suffering all this damage it's ultimate
it's going to kill him and so we had to
know that he was making a huge sacrifice
but also it couldn't be so flashy there
that distracted away from his before we
had some of those those arcs of energy
probably went up into his face more and
then it was like he just looked at that
he didn't look at him right you really
have to be with him in this moment he's
got to be with them exactly
so I feel like you guys had a big
creative challenge here with iron man
dying and that you need to show the
wounds are fatal but you can't be so
gory or grisly as to not make this a
family film exactly and that was
something we explored for a long time
through concept art to start off with
and it's a little bit similar to the
snap we had to allow him to retain his
dignity through this through this moment
how much of this was a makeup versus
digital it's entirely digital so he has
no makeup on him on set it off exactly
and that was a really good decision that
they made to do it that way because if
they had put prosthetics on him
essentially they would have been locked
in to that look yeah more flexibility by
doing it digitally especially when you
know you can achieve a photorealistic
result yeah oh yeah this wood relies on
that I read that most of the wounds are
actually just two-dimensional tracks as
opposed to fall 3d yeah exactly we match
grouped as hid but we found that his
facial performance was so subtle that we
could just using like optical flow type
techniques warp the digital prosthetic
onto the movement of his face so we
didn't have to try and match move his
facial performance the other thing was
for us we had to sit on the secret for
six or eight months and it was like oh
my god if this leaks in trouble well we
can keep a secret here we've never had a
leak touchwood we just have to get get
down into it and they were totally on
board with us and it was a total
surprise for for audiences worldwide can
you speak about anything coming up down
the pipeline at weather well we're
working on the Black Widow movie that's
which opens soon we you know we have an
ongoing relationship with with lavell
and it's fantastic you know the work
that they they get us engaged and as
challenging and diverse and you know
they're great films there's this this
great kind of like storytelling that's
going on with the MCU there it's just
really exciting to be part of Wow well
that's been a crazy episode they're
getting all this information straight
from the source
whenever we're sitting here on the couch
most of the time we're kind of just
guessing so to actually hear a true
professional like say exactly how you
achieve some of these incredible results
is really cool to hear
I mean I've watched some of your stuff
and you guys are pretty onto it so if
you want to learn more about way to go
check out their website you know Adam
fxc onz there's articles on how some of
these effects are done lots of great
information so do not discount just
going and checking out that website it's
great to be here well thank you Matt I
really appreciate it you're a ghost it's
really spooky for a second there because
we're in here hunting ghosts for our
next quarter video but in the meantime
tiny guns - just dropped on the corridor
YouTube channel we got familiar with it
that's where we put all of our short
films so go check it out and this time
you give us a reaction in the comments
below go check it out youtube.com slash
corridor